i mean i think that's right because
these people aren't stupid they're
intelligent people
so
i think you need 2.5 babies in order to
prevent to to um
to continue your culture so in order for
let's say italians to continue living on
as italians need to have 2.5 babies per
family in order for that culture to
continue
for a long time now they've known that
you know a lot of the um certain ethnic
groups why it's been one of them
babies are on the decrease yeah so in
order to control that and keep the white
race alive
these kind of attitudes have been pushed
to say you know what in order to prevent
the white race from being wiped out
essentially we need to decrease the
amount of babies being born by other
ethnic groups and try to increase the
babies being born by white groups if you
look at africa i think in a i feel like
i did an essay on this and that nigeria
in the next 10 to 20 years will have one
of the most the biggest populace of of
people in the world china you know
really had that um a massive population
of people
and
these people venture out and then they
migrate and then they breed with the the
local communities and that kind of
pushes people out
so in order to control um
the the demographic then these are some
of the things that be pushed so it's i
don't think it's a conspiracy it's
factual this is it's written down it's
documented but again the way it's sold
to people
is that it's actually beneficial for the
community now that you said it like that
yeah i actually understand like now that
you said it like that i get it properly
now well and it's it's interesting
because imagine like they were tearing
down statues in the u.s because they
said that the
fount like certain founders were racist
right
fair enough
but why isn't there an outcry that this
woman wanted to control the black
population and so she successfully is
and did it
very should be but again indeed in the
poor communities one of the things that
they lack is proper education
um so yeah resources their resources
their ability to to to gain certain
knowledge and again when it's been sold
to them that it's beneficial as well and
then you look at the black community in
america or anyway and a lot of these lot
attacks you look at some of our role
models
and naturally you're to think that you
know finesse mandarin and shake bambam
on camera
but that's what you should be doing so
our role models
aren't correct either so naturally these
aren't going to be conversations being
pushed by by leaders in the black
community especially over there yeah
um i saw an interesting question in the
super chats
um there's in like interracial dating
i'm starting to do that as well like the
whole um
like obviously you know lifting the
superior like white race and you know
any like colored rays especially black
people because obviously nowadays you
don't see a lot of
black like black relationships going on
what can you do
yeah i'm
well the majority of um
like black people date other black
people in the u.s at least it's like 85
yeah okay so i guess it wouldn't really
then i mean i would think that a
eugenicist would not want that to happen
no yeah which is kind of interesting
because when people talk about
interracial dating like it's always
black and white they never think about
india and south america yeah asian mix
like india yeah india and white
or asian i just think in recent history
like whites and blacks have been so
closely interconnected
that naturally like as
although we see many differences in us
there's probably a lot of similarities
as well
so
um so and i think some of you maybe have
asked answered this question before but
if the women
are able to get an abortion do you think
men should be able to have a financial
abortion 100
yes
yes
yes yeah sorry
sorry about that i'm going to go yes why
because if you get a say like it's like
what me and you were talking about
earlier if i get well say it's
potentially me actually no no i didn't
want to use me because i wouldn't do
this realistically realistically it's
just a woman
saying she wants to get rid of the child
and it's like
she can't
but and then
she's looking for the person who she
intertwined with
no like why are you asking him type of
thing right well it should be about
equality right yeah if we get the option
to not be a mother why don't they get
the option to not be a father yeah
big correct so if i can't tell you
if i don't have a decision telling you
to keep the baby
and i don't have a decision in telling
you not to keep the baby then naturally
um you shouldn't have the decision what
about your money about my money or where
it goes hundreds because i see money as
more more than money like you know money
you can get back what time you can't i
spend time making that money and i have
to give that time something that's not
finite to you i'm sorry that's fine that
to you for something that i didn't want
it doesn't make no sense it doesn't make
no sense cool it takes two to tango and
i understand that but i maintain that
when we don't have equal responsibility
yeah when it comes to a baby a lot of
the responsibility for responsibility
falls on the woman therefore you should
make better decisions who you lie with
and in the event that a baby does come
and this wasn't something that you
wanted then it is what it is what it is
you can't you can't have my money as a
consequence of that yeah
are you guys aware of how abortions are
like how someone gets an abortion i
think the doctor just takes unpleasant
now to pull stuff out doesn't it
isn't there not a different way
there's a couple different ways i know
that there's the
sorry what did you say they like break
the baby apart yeah yeah that's what i
was going to say and then
for some you can take a pill
so i'm not too sure that's really early
on yeah right
it's not early on
like if i feel like i don't know i'm not
too correct maybe paul might know this
but if it's like three weeks four weeks
maybe you can take a pull button then if
the baby has progressed to like a couple
months maybe someone can get them no the
doctors can get their pliers
and then if it goes into the six mark
point i feel like is a cesarean would be
needed type of thing
so yeah so the first option is there's a
pill and i think that's up to 12 weeks
so that essentially starves the baby of
nutrients
and so like they take the pill and
within a couple days they like bleed or
whatever you do but no you're correct
they actually um the other type of
abortion is after 12 weeks they pull the
baby out limb by limb
and then crush its head and pull it out
and i have okay that so
the fun fun links guys
actually watching this no no it's not no
it's not a video it's a picture
no um go to the
second link in the google doc
so i think i remember watching an
american doctor
talk about some of the psychological
damage he has
having
done so many abortions i'm not surprised
yeah so gonna i'm gonna read this um you
want to pull it up um yeah you see the
picture the picture this thing yeah zoom
in and can you zoom in on there
if you can zoom in
i'm gonna show it to them over here too
just give me one second let me let me um
get it for the people at home okay
yeah cool
okay so
uh a sp
a speculum is placed in the vagina and a
tan tana column is clamped onto the lip
of the cervix and a cannula is inserted
into the uterus
then step two the anamonic fluid
placenta and fetus are suctioned through
the cannula into the collection jar this
is the fetus and the placenta are torn
apart in the process
and then see the uterine cavity is
scraped with a
curette to determine whether there are
any significant amount of tissues
remaining so suction abortion also
called vacuum aspiration is the most
common abortion procedure in the world
it falls under the broader banner of
dilation and
curetage which can be performed with a
sharp curette suction cure reddish which
was first used in russia in 1927. 37 30
years later the technique was perfected
in china and today the national abortion
federation reports that virtually all
modern first trimester surgical
abortions are accompanied by vacuum
asper aspiration and roughly in 2015
roughly 73 of abortions were performed
surgically and 86 of these were
performed at or before the 13-week gas
stration
um okay so i'm going to show you guys
the picture
of this
so for everyone at home the pictures
that we are showing you right now is the
ones that
pearl will be showing they try not try
not to click the x okay
not not you sorry
i think i've watched one of those
need to pull it back up